let's evaluate 7 12 minus 6 13. if we're
going to add or subtract fractions we
need to have a common denominator and we
clearly do not have a common denominator
here 12 is a different number than 13.
so let's figure one out a common
denominator well the common denominator
the best one to pick is the least common
multiple of 12 and 13 and since 12 and
13 don't share any factors their least
common multiple is really just going to
be the product of 12 and 13. so it's
going to be 12 times 13 it's going to be
12 times 13 and we'll figure out what
that is in a second but if we're
multiplying the denominator over here by
13 we should also multiply the numerator
by 13. so this should be 7 times 13 and
over here if we're multiplying the
denominator we're multiplying 13 times
12 we should also multiply the numerator
times 12. so 12 times 6. so notice we
haven't changed the value of either
fraction so 7 7 12 times 13 over 13 this
is 6 13 times 12 12 or 1 and of course
we're going to subtract now let's
evaluate these things what is 7 times 13
7 times 10 is 70 7 times 3 is 21 70 plus
21 is 91 and if that was a little bit
too fast feel free to pause and work it
out by hand to verify that 7 times 13 is
91
12 times 13 12 times 12 is 144 add
another 12 to that you're going to get
156
and from that we are going to subtract
12 times 6 is 72
12 times 6 is 72
and
12 times 13 we already figured it out is
156 is 156 and so this is going to be
something over 156 it's going to be 91
91
minus 72
minus 72 over 156 if this was 92 minus
72 it would be 20. this is one less than
that so it's going to be 19. so it's
going to equal 19 over
156 and i think we're done there isn't
there aren't any common factors between
19 and 156 19 is in fact prime so we're
done this is equal to 19 1 56.